is this right because you're so busy
you're doing so many things and i do
want to uh
i mean between brooklyn nine-nine and uh
and
this terrific movie which i wanna talk
to you about which is
i'm gonna say this um i love this film i
really do
and it's one of my favorite movies that
i've seen in during this
whole quarantine and i'm watching
classics like yeah lawrence of arabia
and uh you know citizen kane um
i loved everything about it's a great
story the performances are incredible
uh and it was funny and it was also very
sweet
and then i noticed that you're an
executive producer
in the movie and i thought that must be
kind of cool to be in the film but also
be executive producing it or is it
difficult
uh it's a lot of work you know it was a
small movie with a small budget
but the the pluses for me outweigh the
minuses and
a big part of that for me as an actor is
i can kind of just try stuff out and
then
uh when i watch the edit and feel
humiliated i can just
demand as a producer that it be cut you
know
[Laughter]
so it's kind of like it's it's a chill
vibe for me to bring to the table
yeah yeah but that's you know that's how
i
that's kind of how i've been rolling the
last few years it's kind of i call it
the andre brower rule
you know where i'm a producer on
brooklyn too where i'm like just
surround me with good actors
and then we'll get in the edit and then
anytime i suck we'll just cut to the
good actor
so yeah the cast is terrific they really
are in this movie
yeah you guys all seem to work out and
then you got the incredible uh
uh jk simmons yeah in this
and i mean the man's won an oscar and
he's jonah jameson
and he's also jonah jameson and the
spider-man series yeah
yeah i i tried to get him to talk to me
as jonah jameson
a lot be like call me pretend i'm peter
parker
and be jonah jamison and he's like what
no i'm not gonna do that
and i'd be like do my outgoing uh
voicemail as jonah jameson be like i
need pictures of spider-man
and he's like i'm not going to do that
get out of my trailer
[Laughter]
you're yeah you just sound like not a
good executive producer i was like yeah
i'm a producer you have to
for your fire yeah uh
you know we have a clip here um tell us
what's happening in this clip
in case anyone doesn't know this is
early on in the film
and yes i did use the word film thank
you it was at sundance big deal for me
um it's early on in the field
you have a little gas little gas there
sorry this is one of my daughter's hair
clips nervously picking up
okay uh yes early on in the film
uh and you don't yet
know unless you watch the trailer that
my character has been
reliving the same day many times uh
and i'm i'm courting kristen militi's
character sarah
and sort of gliding through the uh the
wedding and doing some dancing
uh let's take a look at this clip from
palm springs oh yeah
[Music]
and we're gonna show it
you know what's awkward about these
interviews that we do
is that when you come on the real show
yeah we then show to the clip
and it's a really good clip and the
audience would like it and then they
would applaud and we'd come back from it
yeah but when we shoot this we add the
clip later on
so you didn't see the clip and i didn't
see the clip we both know what the clip
is
in this moment it's so fake yeah it's so
fake i go let's take a look
and then it's just you and me going and
then i go wow
that was great but we didn't just see
anything we didn't see it can we
pretend like the clip just ended again
and then you guys can put in
applause and we can do the like normal
thing and i'll just say
i'll take a sip of my water like it just
came out of the clip okay let's take a
look at this
uh clip uh from uh from palm springs
we're back wow
yeah i mean it's a fun movie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i miss that stuff i miss those little
things when is it
no you're a you're a smart guy and
you're behind the scenes in the
business oh um
when do you think we people get back to
acting and making things again
i have a feeling like it can go one of
two ways right
we'll get it under control there's a
vaccine or we
come up with some great protocol that
actually feels safe
or and hear me out
everything goes mocap motion capture
and we all get like ready player one
style mocap
rigs in our homes and you can audition
this way
and then actually shoot this way it's
like avatar style but it's like
everyone's in their own home robert
ramirez in his home wearing a motion
capture suit you're in your home
yeah and like ready player one
with a diaper because you know you don't
want to waste time by leaving set
so we all have our you know that's also
from ready player one the book
not for all you you know posers who just
like
saw the movie they cut out the diaper
thing
yes also the virtual sex they cut out
such a sellout
spielberg unbelievable anyway
but yeah i think you know if you if you
could get like a really good mocap rig
and like a little blue screen or green
screen room in your house
right with one of those you know 360
cameras and a diaper
a big old diaper yeah like a big like
multiple trips diaper
you know wait so you'd be using the
diaper over and over and over again
without changing it
yeah so you can just shoot for days you
know like in ready player won the book
not the movie which was a sell out that
okay um yeah i did like the movie though
yeah i like the movie yeah
that was a good move you still get to be
in the business